[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouveau ses tweets
échos aujourd'hui focus sur
l'aéronautique à l'occasion d'un
séminaire
quel espace dans 20 ans organisé à
l'estaca une école d'ingénieurs située à
montigny le bretonneux
des rencontres qui sont réservés aux
étudiants et aux spécialistes de
l'aérospatiale c'est l'occasion donc de
faire un point sur l'aéronautique sur le
territoire sommaire nous ferons un point
avec pascal bidan directeur délégué de
l'école d'ingénieurs l'estaca situe à
montigny le bretonneux
avec lui nous verrons les forces du
secteur de l'industrie aérospatiale sur
saint quentin en yvelines
nous découvrirons la plateforme
d'intégration et de test en cotutelle
avec le cnrs situé à l'université
versailles saint quentin
créée en 2009 la structure tests des
équipements scientifiques et spatiaux
parole à lionel de la cei est au
conseiller auprès du président directeur
général de dassault aviation et nous
expliquera l'importance du séminaire
quel espace dans 20 ans le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines est une terre
comptant de nombreuses entreprises
d'aéronautique spatial tels que safran
snecma magny les hameaux airbus n space
à elancourt atos aux clayes-sous-bois ou
encore assister nous france à montigny
le bretonneux le secteur sur 50 ans en
chiffres c'est 60 établissements dans
l'aéronautique le spatial la défense et
la sécurité
avec plus de 14 mille emplois directs
c'est pour cette raison que l'école
d'ingénieurs estaca s'est installé dans
l'agglomération parlons-en avec son
directeur délégué pascal bidon bonjour
bonjour
alors ce matin c'est une journée
importante
c'est une journée extrêmement important
pour nous puisque c'est la première
journée d'une semaine une semaine du
séminaire espace du groupe usa et qui se
tient pour la première fois ici à
l'estaca c'est important d'être sur ce
territoire à saint quentin en yvelines
avec toutes ces entreprises ça crée une
émulation
alors ça crée beaucoup d'élimination ce
séminaire espace a lieu tous les ans
c'est la première fois que ces minérale
espace a lieu en région parisienne mais
en fait la région parisienne
on ne sait pas toujours c'est la
première région de france en terme
d'emplois dans le secteur aéronautique
et et secteur spatial à peu près au même
niveau que toulouse la région aussi
thani est ici en ile de france
même dans les yvelines et à saint
quentin en yvelines on a beaucoup
d'entreprises avec qui on peut
travailler dans le secteur spatial vous
échangé beaucoup avec le secteur
paris-saclay que les différentes
entreprises
alors oui bien sûr alors à la fois donc
nous sommes complètement implantée
maintenant depuis deux ans ici dans le
cluster paris saclay nous participons
réseau spatiale de l'université paris
saclay et puis nous travaillons surtout
avec les entreprises donc avec thales
donc il ya 50 et en yvelines airbus
defence and space monkey et à edimbourg
le laboratoire le latmos qui accueillit
en cours donc on est vraiment dans cette
optique au système de saclay et cet
échange et se traduit comment avec les
élèves c'est beaucoup d'interventions là
on sait qu'il ya une personne d'un
d'airbus qui va intervenir mais c'est
pendant les cours il ya des devoirs
c'est des stages alors exactement vous
avez des éléments d'abord sont des cours
donc et dans une école d'ingénieurs ont
fait plus des cours avec un prof qui est
des livres à savoir c'est très
interactif et c'est très important
d'avoir des personnes qui sont en
activité professeur dans le médecin donc
ça ce sont les cours après sont les
projets l'estac est une école qui a une
pédagogie fortement orientée projet et
donc les étudiants travaillent sur des
cahiers des charges sur des cas concrets
qui sont amenés par des intervenants
du monde industriel des grandes agences
nationales spatiale comme le cnes par
exemple ils travaillent sur des cas
concrets
1 ça leur permet également d'apprendre à
travailler ensemble à plusieurs alors
soit entre étudiants de l'estaca soit
avec des étudiants d'autres écoles y
compris des écoles qui sont pas des
écoles d'ingénieurs pour donc développé
apporter des solutions innovantes à des
problèmes concrets
après vous avez parlé des stages on a
des entreprises qui sont juste à côté et
puis jusqu'à bien sur l'insertion
professionnelle on a encore une fois
beaucoup d'emplois en région par lien le
secteur spatial
et pour finir quels sont vraiment vos
échanges avec l'agglomération de saint
quentin
il ya vraiment un suivi vous collaborez
alors les échanges sont très nombreux et
je voudrais en citer un qui est très
important qui est lié à
l'entrepreneuriat donc on travaille avec
sky tueur donc et le donc l' incubateur
de start up qui est juste juste
d'ailleurs ouvert la nuit en cours et
nous revient de créer à l'école là on
l'avait fait il ya deux ans à titre
expérimental et depuis cette année on a
une option entrepreneuriat alors ça
c'est très important d'être accompagné
par exemple par l'agglomération de saint
quentin pour que nos étudiants qui
veulent créer leur start up en sortant
de l'école
c'est une autre façon de débuter sa
carrière professionnelle et bien qu'ils
puissent être accompagnés par des gens
qui leur donne des conseils et puis
aussi
les personnes qui peuvent investir et
les accompagner pour faire grandir des
start up et bien je vous remercie
merci à vous et bonne journée et prenons
maintenant la direction de l'université
versailles saint quentin nous allons
découvrir la pite la plateforme
d'intégration et de test en cotutelle
avec le cnrs elle doit permettre d'
intégrer et tester notamment des
équipements embarqués sur des satellites
ou des sondes interplanétaires pour
l'étude de l'espace et des planètes du
système solaire
reportage créer les conditions d'une
mission spatiale sur terre pour
permettre aux astronautes de se préparer
à tous les risques
c'est le but de la plateforme
d'intégration intitulé la pite nés en
2009 une structure de montage qui teste
des équipements scientifiques et
spatiaux une machine qui nous permet de
recréer l'environnement de l'espace donc
le vide
et puis le chaud et le froid donc on va
y mettre à l'intérieur des équipements
qui sont en cours de développement donc
là vous en avez un
un exemple et puis on va piloter la
machine pour recréer en fait le vide
et puis ensuite faire subir à
l'équipement des températures chaudes et
des températures froides qui seront
celles qu'il verra lorsqu'il sera dans
l'espace sur le satellite
la piste est par exemple la résistance
du matériel de recherche au vide spatial
ou vibrations de la phase de tir d'une
fusée des nano satellites engins d'une
masse inférieure à 10 kg sont soumis à
des tests thermiques extrêmes note qu en
fait a été pensé pour pouvoir passer
d'abord des équipements embarqués donc
pas des satellites complet
cela dit elle est aujourd'hui
suffisamment grande a fait à peu près 3
mètres cubes pour pouvoir passer des
petits satellites et notamment ce qu'on
appelle des nano satellites qui sont des
objets très à la mode actuellement et on
en a notamment testé l'année dernière
trois en même temps ce qui était une
première en france
et donc cette cuve la permet notamment
de faire ce type de test en ce moment la
test des objets qui iront dès 2018
destination de mercure pour un retour en
faisons un point avec lionel de la
sayette haut conseiller du pdg de
dassault aviation une entreprise de
poids sur le territoire bonjour bonjour
monsieur
alors pourquoi participer à ce type
d'événement c'est un séminaire organisé
par le groupe isa et qui se passe ici à
l'estaca c'est une opportunité
exceptionnelle pour des étudiants qui
viennent à la fois du sud de la france
de toulouse de salon super héros un
super héros à toulouse absolument mais
en fait maintenant 10 lisa est super
héros salon de provence et l'école de
l'air l'estaca et puis les n'zima qui
vient de poitiers de travailler ensemble
de réfléchir avec une perspective qui
est pas seulement du court terme pour
les cours mais de réfléchir à une vision
un peu plus avancés sur l'espace c'est
créer une certaine émulation entre
élèves entre jeunes pousses on peut dire
ça comme ça
vous pouvez dire une émulation jeudi
d'abord une coopération parce qu'ils se
connaissent pas à l'entrée hôte du
séminaire ensuite ils auront l'occasion
de définir ensemble des projets pour
lesquels ils auraient envie de s'engager
en travaillant ensemble
c'est important que ça se passe sur le
territoire
beaucoup d'entreprises ici dont dassault
la snecma au site airbus c'est important
il ya effectivement en france deux pôles
importants ici en ile-de-france et à
toulouse en occitanie qui ont
progressivement développé des capacités
spatiales sur des modélisations puis
ensuite se sont spécialisés vers la
réalisation d'un côté des satellites est
ici plus des systèmes lanceur et de la
propulsion alors c'est important
effectivement pour les industriels de
s'investir dans les grandes écoles pour
deux raisons la première parce qu'ils
ont eux mêmes à leur tour a expliqué
comment ils ont appris et mis au point
des processus efficaces et dans l'autre
sens il est clair qu'ils viennent pour
donner des cours ou pour accompagner des
projets pour repérer des étudiants qui
sont passionnés et qui pourront ensuite
rentrés dans leur entreprise
donc c'est important donc d'être là de
voir ces jeunes et aussi les modules qui
sont proposés durant ces quatre jours
soit intéressant ça va leur apporter
quelque chose
oui parce que les cours sont quand même
en général à l'intérieur d'un syllabus
qui est très construit pendant toute une
année scolaire ils ont des projets sur
lesquels il travaille maintenant de plus
en plus par groupes parfois même avec
des partenaires internationaux mais du
temps pour réfléchir à ce qu'est la
vision avancé d'un domaine que ce soit
les avions gros porteurs
les avions militaires ou ici la partie
spatiale
ça ce n'est pas si fréquent et nous
pensons qu'il faut construire nos
syllabus intégrer ceux ci dans les
emplois du temps pour qu'il puisse avoir
l'habitude quand ils veulent construire
ensuite un business plan de réfléchir
avec une vue qui est largement plus
ouverte
il faut qu'ils traitent bien sûr des
produits et des services mais des
partenaires des processus qui veulent
utiliser des business plans qui vont
construire et puis quelque part il va
rester une culture de cette construction
qui leur sera très utile à l'avenir dans
leur vie professionnelle
ça leur permet de créer des contacts et
vous parler d'eux
vie professionnelle c'est important
qu'ils aient souvent ce type de modules
à l'avenir pour ensuite venir toquer aux
portes des entreprises
oui dès la première année les étudiants
maintenant construisent une petite liste
vous pouvez appeler ça un réseau mais
une série d'entreprises dans lesquelles
ils aimeraient travailler et on leur
donne aussi ses opportunités à travers
les stages et quand ils sont en stage de
courte durée par exemple de travaux
d'études recherche ou de plus longue
durée sur six mois voire plus d'études
de projets là ils ont la possibilité
d'apprécier les qualités des entreprises
dans lesquelles ils vont peut-être
démarrer leur activité professionnelle
mais je pense que le réseau qui
autrefois était très hexagonale devient
de plus en plus un réseau européen voire
international avec beaucoup de
coopération dans le groupe isa et qui
ont été développés avec des universités
américaines
et ça aussi c'est important puisque dans
le futur ils vont jamais travailler seul
ils vont travailler en environnement
multiculturel et si l'on était à
berkeley à stanford à elie nice ils
auront cette capacité de s'adapter très
rapidement
pour finir ils sont sur la bonne voie
donc à ils sont ici sur plus qu'une
bonne voie et c'est sur une bonne
trajectoire pour une mise en orbite
puisque nous sommes dans le secteur
spatial
et bien je vous remercie merci bien
monsieur
[Musique]
le jeudi 20 avril de 9h30 à 11h30 un
atelier vous permettra de découvrir le
processus du micro entreprenariat régime
juridique régime social spécifique et
des régimes fiscaux cela se déroule au
ski cube à guyancourt au ski cube
toujours apprenez à financer votre
innovation avec bpi france financement
et accompagnement des entreprises
innovantes de l'amorçage au
développement international
vous saurez tout cela se déroule le
mardi 25 avril de 9h30 à 11h30
c'est la fin de ce set 8 échos merci de
nous avoir suivis prochain numéro le 20
avril et surtout bonne journée à tous
[Musique]